jetzt wahrscheinlich gerade dieses video
angeklickt weil den titel gesehen habt
und euch einfach gedacht habt hey was
geht denn da jetzt aber max julen und
ich haben uns auf youtube sma video
angeguckt
falls ihr nicht wisst was das ist ja da
sitzen leute vor ihrer kamera und
schmerzen ins mikrofon
so ich mal ganz gut gegen die medien
werfen viele leute kommen dann durch und
haben dadurch stress abkommen zu hohe
ezb pm beim axel und mir hat das ganze
einfach mal so eine gewisse form von
aggression und verwirrung ausgelöst weil
uns einfach wirklich gegenwehr lautstark
ins ohr schmatz und da haben wir uns
gedacht hey wir haben uns gerade was zu
essen bestellt weil wir hunger hatten
warum machen wir nicht einfach mal auch
ein sma video und versuchen das auch mal
so zu machen
deswegen alle unter euch die sma videos
feiern das vielleicht zum lernen hören
oder zum einschlafen oder keine ahnung
was das ist überhaupt nicht negativ
gemeint dieses video wir wollen hiermit
keine irgendwie angreifen keinen kanal
irgendwie fertig machen kein youtuber
fertig machen erstmal videos hochlädt
ich finde es sogar im gegenteil sehr
interessant und maxim und ich habe uns
einfach gefragt können wir das auch
machen und dabei ernst bleiben können
wir nicht aber seht einfach selbst denn
jetzt kommt hier ein best-of max luca
jule essen was schmerz ins mikrofon und
länder
als erstes update 1 nächstes nahmen
einen gott
[Musik]
[Applaus]
als nächstes kartoffelpüree
[Musik]
diese chips wir bestellt haben
da keine checkpoints
sie habe
ein loch
rauben
[Musik]
das sind
deine chips
[Musik]
respekt das feedback das machen wir ja
damit will ich das sollte die videos
allerdings auch beenden meine damen und
herren wie gesagt maximum und ich habe
es einfach etwas zu essen bestellt und
haben uns gedacht bevor wir das hier
normal essen muss einfach dabei auf
prozent sma und versuchen das ganze auch
mal zu machen und ich glaube wir sind
grandios gescheitert an alle die jetzt
ma feiern sich das regelmäßig anhören
und auch an allererste mal youtuber die
dazu videos hochladen bitte bitte haltet
uns nicht wir wollten das ganze einfach
mal testen das soll alles auf einer
lustigen ebene nachgemacht sein dann ist
euch gefallen hat dann das gerne ein
leichter scheint das ist die kommentare
ob ihr selber sma feiert ob ihr euch das
selber anhört und jetzt
[Musik]